by the way there'll be spoilers in this
video but i assume you already knew that
so halloween kills opens right away with
a retcon and bringing back officer
hopkins who presumably died in halloween
2018 who was one of the people
responsible for bringing in michael
myers
and when i say he presumably died in the
last movie that's being very generous
because he was stabbed three times in
the neck then the scene played out for
an additional three minutes as he was
bleeding out they ran him over with a
freaking car and then he was laying
there for however long until a random
npc shows up and finds him and plugs his
holes with a scarf i'd assume the blood
loss alone would kill him but i feel
like the car should have easily pushed
him into the finish line
then the cop wakes up and the first
thing that come out of his mouth is so
cheesy and on the nose
he needs to die
and i'm the one that's gonna get him in
a wheelchair
i wouldn't expect that to be the first
thing on his mind on the verge of dying
but alright then then the movie cuts to
a flashback of a young officer hawkins
bringing in michael myers and that whole
situation was pretty painful to watch
officer hawkins and his partner decided
to check michael myers house since he
was somewhere in the area while clearing
the building hawkins's partner goes into
the upstairs room in which michael
originally killed his sister and for
some reason he decided to dramatically
look out the window like michael until
getting jumped by him like excuse me
you're tracking down a dangerous killer
and you're going to put your guard down
in his house
without fully clearing the whole
building
that's pretty wild and then hawkins
comes in and during this hostage
scenario he shoots his partner in the
neck which causes him to pause and start
his partner while michael casually walks
out of the room
like okay at the very least you could
have shot michael after having shot your
partner but since he didn't it made his
death feel so stupid and pointless
after gawking at his partner for a
couple seconds michael slowly walks down
the staircase while hawkins tries to
shoot at him a couple feet away and
misses
overall though this 12-minute opening
scene is kind of pointless given that
officer hawkins is hospital ridden for
the entirety of the movie this
introduction makes it seem like he's
going to be the main character although
that's not the case and i don't know how
he can be the main character in the next
movie if his leg is shattered but oh
well
going back to present day the writers
introduce us to a big batch of
disposable characters that may or may
not get killed throughout the movie this
combined bar scene is about 10 minutes
long and features no main characters so
it feels kind of directionless since the
pov keeps changing around
also during this whole scene the writers
keep doing exposition dumps and
recapping what happened in the original
halloween by having the survivors of
michael's attacks tell their stories
which is really boring considering that
all this information is redundant and
the audience already knows everything
that they're saying
there's not much else here to really
break down so let's jump over to michael
myers escaping laurie's burning house
for this scene there is one really funny
moment that i have to point out i find
it really funny that there is a
firefighter shooting water at michael as
if he's some hot girl washing a car
everyone's building axes and saws while
this guy is making michael wet
and i'm surprised the man didn't even
flinch when michael was coming at him he
had one purpose in life and he did not
disappoint
and that's it for this scene i just
needed you to witness that
20 minutes go by nothing really happens
we have michael randomly killing some
people the continued bar scene lori
going through surgery and introducing a
gay couple living in the myers house
that will be relevant later on
now we are finally with some of our main
characters karen lori strode's daughter
and her granddaughter allison in this
scene the cops are interviewing them
about what happened in the last movie
and yet again like the bar scene we are
getting boring recap that has nothing of
value we're almost halfway through the
movie and only one substantial thing has
happened which was a two minute scene
going back to the interview though the
cops told him that michael survived the
burning house and allison's reaction is
so stupid that it's downright hilarious
michael myers is alive
what
her screeching what out of nowhere
honestly made me start laughing that
added with two back-to-back whip
transitions makes this borderline a
comedic scene what were the writers and
editors thinking for this
so moving on the group of characters in
the bar decided that they need to take
matters into their own hands because
apparently the cops can't which we'll go
into later allison decides to join this
crusade and there are two groups one car
worth legacy characters and the other
with allison her boyfriend and his dad
for the legacy character group they come
across some kids and park their car to
tell them to go home
while they are parked michael jumps on
the roof of the car and the nurse lady
gets out with a gun and then disappears
like did she just run away while michael
was on the car killing her friends then
she conveniently reappears when everyone
in the car dies and tries to kill
michael i'm just confused by the course
of decisions here if she was out of the
car and michael was sitting on the roof
then she could have easily shot him but
didn't and ran away until changing her
mind and coming back
and it didn't even matter because she
misses all of her shots while michael is
sitting still in the front seat what are
you waving at that's a really
embarrassing sequence so she has the
most pathetic death i've ever seen
michael even stares at her in awe as to
how stupid that whole scenario was
after that [ __ ] show the last survivor
of the group runs away and makes
probably the most stupid decision you
could possibly make michael is walking
after her while she is sprinting and
this girl is like oh god he's going to
catch me i need to hide as if he was
going to catch up to her while she was
running away
it doesn't matter though because she
miraculously survives and i thought she
was going to die for making that
terrible decision
this whole situation in which tommy
doyle another legacy character from the
first movie tries to gather the
community to catch michael seems like a
bad idea mostly because you have a bunch
of inexperienced idiots running around
trying to find a serial killer and as a
result of that more innocent people die
you would think tommy would feel half
responsible for these casualties because
they clearly aren't fit to catch him the
movie tries to justify this logic why
the sheriff's department not doing a
good enough job to take michael myers
down
surely if there was a crisis on this
magnitude you'd be able to get support
from other towns nearby
but that's not the case i guess and the
cops are apparently just inept in this
movie
especially since they all seem to be in
this hospital and not patrolling the
streets
fast forwarding ahead we have a scene
where there's a couple in the myers
house and michael drops in to say hi
the scene starts in such a dumb way in
which michael knocks on the back door
the character checks the backyard and
closes the door without locking it
i'd be scared to tell if some random
person is on her back porch knocking on
the door but this guy forgets to lock it
are you kidding me and then surprise
surprise michael just waltzes on in
also the dialogue between this couple is
so cringy
big john
yes little john how can i take them
seriously when they're calling each
other big and little john and honestly
just feels like the writers are trolling
us at this point while clearing the
house michael gets the drop on big john
and kills him
sad big john you'll never be forgotten
press f my brothers
so yeah little john comes in and finds
his body and is just too devastated that
big john isn't in his life anymore and
decides to let michael kill him
yikes that sure was a scene that the
writers wrote into this movie
going back to the hospital
some unknown crazy guy broke out of the
bus in the first movie and randomly
wanders in and everyone is like is that
michael
he even walks past some security guards
who you'd think would be aware of the
fugitives on the loose also wouldn't
they be checking him out if there's a
massive deep cut on his forehead
then people rapidly come to the
conclusion that it is in fact michael
myers without anyone really getting a
visual on him
which how could anyone who did see him
identify this 5 foot guy as being
michael when he should be like 6 feet
tall while wearing a jumpsuit and a mask
but i guess the police didn't give any
form of description of the killer on the
loose
so anyways this ends up starting a mob
and to be honest i don't know why the
hospital is so damn crowded but whatever
now there's a hoard of human zombies
running around the hospital chasing
after quote unquote michael myers
there's even a funny moment where karen
is running up a sterile with a cop and
one of the hospital workers yeets her
ass onto the ground
like what are you doing that was so
unnecessary she ends up catching up to
the mental asylum patient and her grand
plan is to lock him in this hallway to
which he gets cornered and everyone
starts banging and destroying the
windows like animals
the movie basically makes the statement
here that evil is corrupting this town
and is driving people to do irrational
things it turns into a cringey
ham-fisted message of mob mentality
being bad but the fact that literally
everyone is doing this so blindly is
pretty shocking and idiotic i feel like
most of these people would just let the
cops do their job and detain him given
that there's a ton of cops already in
the hospital but nope the mental asylum
patient gets scared and jumps out of a
window tommy runs up to the body and is
like what do you mean how do we know if
it's not him
he's always won a mass clear how do we
know it's not him like i'm sorry but
this scrawny little man is not michael
myers
then the cop yelling over his body says
this
now he's turning us into monsters
thank you writers it wasn't obvious
enough that everyone was acting like
deranged psychopaths
especially after lori strode said this
it's what he's done to this town these
people
decent people so i don't know why the
writers had the need to tell us that
twice while it was very obvious what the
movie was trying to say
so after that egregious sequence that
offers nothing of value to the overall
movie we have the last group out looking
for michael myers
while trying to find him we finally have
a smart moment a round of applause
everyone and that smart moment was that
lonnie a random character in the
flashback who ran into michael as a kid
tracked michael's trail of crime which
leads back to his original house
congrats man that was half smart but
then when they get there
he decides to leeroy jenkins's eyes into
the house alone and dies right away so
this man was smart enough to put
together some clues but is
simultaneously brain dead enough to the
point of running into a hostile house
containing a mass murderer by himself
also why is lonnie hunting michael with
his son this does not seem like the best
father and son activity to be doing
dummy you brought your kid to the belly
of the beast yeah no like hey son let's
go out and kill ourselves michael myers
that sounds like a grand old time when
did the notion of parents wanting to
protect their children disappear in the
writers room for this movie or in
general taking teenager slash young
adults with him on this endeavor
but hey don't think about that this just
adds more characters to throw into
michael's kill counts so the remaining
characters in the group lonnie's son and
allison enter the house and look around
for michael lonnie finds his dad
obviously killed and michael jumps out
of a closet
and yet again the character has about a
10 second reaction time and doesn't
shoot michael as he's approaching him
lonnie only shoots his gun until after
he gets pinned which is very in fashion
for the movie at this point the audience
should already know that michael is
invulnerable and you don't need to
compromise the intellect of every
character to save this reveal for the
end of the movie
alison hears lonnie getting rolled by
michael and runs in with her shotgun
which obviously gets bashed away
why do these characters even bother to
use guns at this point
then the movie falls into the trope of
the antagonist being able to kill the
protagonist but instead throws him away
to safety
if that was any other character michael
would have disarmed them and then
stabbed them to death but nope plot
armor prevails against the almighty
michael myers
moving ahead lonnie slowly gets killed
as alison just screams at michael for a
full minute and still getting picked up
by him and just before she is about to
die a deus ex machina karen shows up to
save her life
this movie actually just did two movie
tropes in the span of two minutes
congratulations writers truly amazing
writing here on display karen then takes
michael's mask while he was stunned on
the ground and is going to lure him into
a trap i don't know why she didn't just
impale him in the head with the
pitchfork but whatever for the trap
itself it all plays out logically and
then the twist reveal happens in which
michael can't actually die
which i assumed was kind of common
knowledge given that the original
halloween ends with michael getting shot
five times and falling off a two-story
balcony and surviving
through all the exposition dumping in
this movie i guess all the characters
forgot about that massive important
detail
however the writers and halloween kills
act like michael being unkillable is
some groundbreaking revelation when we
already know that's the case and
everyone should too
at least for the fire in the first movie
it was plausible for michael to burn
away into ashes but for the trap at the
end of this movie some bats knives and
guns should theoretically do nothing
against him
so yeah that all happens and michael
teleports behind karen while in the
myers house and kills her i'm not going
to bother questioning how michael made
it over there so quickly but yeah that
just happens
also by the way if you're confused why i
haven't even talked about laurie strode
throughout the whole video that's
because she's been sitting in a hospital
the entire movie
great job writers for sidelining one of
your most interesting characters
i don't know why they made it to where
michael gets a practically killing blow
and lorry in the first movie of the
trilogy so now the only logical outcome
is for her to be bedridden in a hospital
if anything it's still going to be
contrived in the next movie if she's
fine and is able to fight michael again
same thing for officer hawkins who was
also in the hospital all movie
there are some stupid aspects in
halloween 2018 but i think halloween
kills goes off the rails from the sheer
amount of stupidity in the movie let me
know what you thought about the movie in
the comments and make sure to check out
my other devoidlogic videos in the end
screen